so i watched the season three premiere
and it was so good i mean the first five
minutes is this beautiful tribute to
frontline workers during the pandemic
how will the pandemic continue to affect
the characters for the rest of the
season
yeah that's a great question i think
that um
you know it's certainly taken a toll on
everybody and
and you know the title the first episode
is the new normal so i think it's about
what is the new normal and how do we get
back to that or or what are we
um coming back to you know in the sense
of
uh for max he's dealing with he's left
his
daughter luna with um his with george's
parents and is coming to terms with uh
is it time to bring her back
is it safe is it not safe am i being a
bad dad by not
having her here or am i doing the right
thing by having her away so he's
wrestling with that
and um you know hell like helen freema's
character is
wrestling with sort of intimacy feels
strange because you know she's been so
isolated and in this thing and um
you know janet's character bloom is
wrestling with
missing the fight and the intensity of
that and so it's just about sort of
coming back to some sort of
stasis whatever that is yeah now you
yourself tested positive for covid19
back in september so how are you feeling
now
uh it was a little before that actually
it was last spring but i'm feeling
um good thanks and fortunately it wasn't
um horrible for me it wasn't fun uh
but uh but it wasn't um it wasn't
life-threatening thank goodness
and um so yeah
well that's good i mean you know
obviously if you're going through
something like this
you don't know what's going to happen
like did does it make the storylines for
this season feel more real
like do you feel you know even more
connected to it
yeah definitely i mean you know just
because having gone through it it's like
it's not something that's
abstract something that you experience
you know and that obviously
so many people have dealt with them and
unfortunately so many people have had
such a
tougher time with um but you know i will
say it does
feel optimistic these days um
most importantly movie theaters are
opening in new york this weekend which
is really
that's been my number one priority for
for some time now so i'm excited for
that
but it does feel like with the vaccine
rolling out that that people you know my
parents have gotten that people are
getting it and
it's it's exciting to to see progress
finally moving in the right direction
you know what's so great about this show
is um obviously the show deals with
really heartbreaking moments and story
lines but there's also lightness to it
and there's fun moments how important is
it finding that balance for this show
yeah so important i think because on one
hand you don't want to do a disservice
to the pandemic and
the toll it's taken and the hardship
it's been particularly for our frontline
workers who sacrificed so much so you
want to
be honest and pay tribute to that and
and be honest
um in reflecting that but then at the
same time you know you're making a show
and you don't want you know the world
is tough right now and this has been
hard on everybody and you don't want to
sort of further you know bring people
down by
um reinforcing that hardship constantly
so it's
i think it's important on the show and
and honestly in our own lives to
find that lightness and and that joy and
that humor and that connection
which we've all been been been missing
so much to remind us what it is that
we're
fighting for you know well some of my
favorite moments
uh this season so far have been with dr
shin of course played by daniel
day kim love him love you know this new
addition
um obviously dr shin and max have
different ways
of how they work so how would you
describe the dynamic between these two
this season
you know uh well first off daniel's an
amazing actor and an amazing
guy and a really wonderful presence to
have on set um
very positive and and very dedicated to
what he does and
just a very welcome addition um and his
character
is great you know max and cassian are
um sort of at a distance
but tied together by um
helen uh between them and that they both
have a close relationship
with her and you know um
i think helen dating uh cassian um
whatever it is they were doing whatever
it is there they have in the future
is brings up questions for max
like how do i feel about this person
because they you know max and helen have
had such
a close intimate relationship um
that has been sort of undefined uh at
times and a lot of
you know max was going through a lot so
it was um
you know not something he could examine
at a certain point but now
you know things are changing and so you
know cassian's presence is just a great
i think catalyst for figuring out what
is my relationship with this person you
know
so you're saying we're going to see a
little bit of jealousy for max
hey i didn't use the jealousy word i'll
say
perhaps a bit of curiosity a
a bit of caution um a bit of um
yes perhaps jealousy indeed i think you
know
those relationships are interesting uh
in our lives where we're close with
someone but we don't know exactly what
to call it or
how to define it and i think that's max
and helen so yeah i think watching her
uh smiling and happy with somebody else
but this other guy who's very charming
and and everything that cassian that
daniel is
um is uh it's tough it brings some stuff
up for sure amazing i love this for
somebody who wants to see
helen max together i am happy about this
and cannot wait for the rest of the
episodes
um you know max has always been about
change when it comes to the health care
system
how do you think the pandemic has really
like even a stronger fire for him to
make changes
yeah i think i think it's made him
realize he has to have a wider lens
and and see things in a bigger scope you
know because
i think he just realized like like many
of us did how unprepared
we were for something like this um
and that the system was so overwhelmed
by this going forward it's not only how
can i help or how can i fix this but
it's um are there parts of the system
that we sort of need to tear down and
build up again
in a way that um that works
for everybody so i think he's i think
it's further committed him
to trying to change things for the
better um and realizing that there is a
real
cost to things when the system isn't
working
at its best uh it was so great to see a
little bit of dr reynolds at the
end of the season three premiere
obviously he left
in season two will we get to see more of
him this season
absolutely we um yes that was that was
my favorite part of the show
to seeing that handsome face at the end
and um
you know um i i love giaco max
uh and floyd have a great friendship
that we don't explore
often but i love when we do and i hope
that we get into more because i love
working with them and yes we could we
couldn't do the show without jocko he's
part of the family and as his reynolds
and so
um there's a lot of great stuff coming
with him okay good to know
um now you start in black landsman in
2018 and when you think of
you know everything that's gone in the
past year black lives matter movement
how proud are you to have been a part of
that film oh man i mean i'm just honored
to have worked with uh
spike and and and john david and um and
be a part of telling that story and uh
yeah you know it's it's it's crazy how
relevant that film was
in 2018 um uh
when you think about the the clan and
just where we are these days and things
and then
you know in recent events you see people
wearing shirts
when they're storming the capital that
say things that are
i don't know what to say less than ideal
and i think a film like that is
important particularly you know what
spike did with the end
by showing that real footage and just
bringing it all back to the reality
um of some of the things we're living
through so yeah it was an honor and i i
would love to
work with him again and jump at the
opportunity and um
you know those stories that are based on
true experiences
and and true lot true people um as that
was
are the most exciting projects for me to
what both to watch and to be a part of
yeah and just to wrap things up you know
you've been with this character now
three seasons you've been with the show
with this cast
how much fun are you still having with
this whole show
so much fun you know it was really weird
to go back to work
uh in october because you know we just
like everybody i've just been
isolated and quarantined and not working
and you know
spending too much time and sweatpants
and things
yeah you know and then and then go back
to a set with like a ton of people
and lines memorizing work to do and just
the whole hustle and bustle that the job
is you
you know you totally forget and so at
first it was kind of
you know destabilizing and like well how
do we do this again but then it was such
a welcome
return to this family um and these
stories that i love
being a part of telling and it was um
it's just a wonderful home to come back
to
and and the people that we get to work
with are are really great and so
um it's it's it's been awesome it's been
really fun
see everybody again